let's let's bring the war to a modern
conversation we have this from politico
quote we see the storm coming u.s
struggles to contain a deepening global
food crisis but in officials are
scrambling to limit the damage from fast
spreading food shortages sparked by
russia's war in ukraine but they face
complex political and logistical
challenges i just want to say i i
certainly i've said it before putin has
a lot to blame for the escalating prices
the war it's a tit for tat and often you
get sanctions now putin saying he's not
going to export agriculture unless it's
to a friendly nation you've got the
rising fertilizer costs all of this very
much starts from this war however food
costs were already skyrocketing well
before this war started food shortages
were already hitting everybody well
before this war started i definitely
think the biden admin and the media are
like it's all putin's fault it's like
nah it's your fault too
but
ladies and gentlemen i hope you're
prepared for the worst because they're
saying the word famine now it was the
french foreign minister said global
famine the i think it was the un health
food program said i don't know if he
said famine
but even biden is saying famine in
europe famine is the word oh boy well i
think it's more like famine in africa
right the problem being that it's food
resources in europe are like pro one of
our like key to providing food in africa
but this is the surface layer you know
vladimir putin says the poorest
countries are going to be impacted very
heavily by this global food shortage
but of course it's going to impact us
very severely it already is uh in spain
they're already food rationing in
germany prices are already up uh 20 to
50 percent so this is the funny thing
you know you just had a look when i said
spain was doing food rationing they're
doing it at supermarkets i want you guys
to imagine this imagine what your life
is going to be like when you go to a
supermarket and you go to get chicken
and there's a sign saying only one
chicken item per customer could you
imagine that i could because it happened
two years ago we saw all of these food
shortages and our supermarkets were
doing food rationing you'd go in and say
only one beef item per customer i went
in and i was like i want to get some
boneless chicken wings
they're called wangs or whatever because
they can't call them wings and it was
like a big sign says only two per
customer so you could get like one thing
of nuggets and maybe a thing of breast
that's all they would allow
the worst thing that happening in europe
now it's happening in spain germany as i
mentioned prices are skyrocketing so
with the fur with the lack of fertilizer
it's not just going to be poor nations
that suffer oh they're going to suffer
the worst yes but i'm very much
concerned about what's gonna happen here
in the u.s what's gonna happen to cities
when these people who are entitled often
morbidly obese how are they gonna deal
with this how are they gonna you know
what are they gonna do when they can't
get the food they want
hopefully they'll be they'll be looking
up on the internet how to lose weight
how to fast because the first three or
four days of fasting is brutal but this
is like you know this is different like
you know the covet stuff hit our supply
chain right this is europe's no it's our
supply chain we we get a ton of our
fertilizer from russia
most of our fertilizer comes from russia
and fertilizer costs for american
farmers is up 300 percent that's that's
fair i didn't realize that
and not to mention uh fuel costs too but
it also means what what will what will
the bite administration do for europe
biden's already talked about taking our
food and giving it away to other
countries so we are going to be strained
on this one
now the worrying thing is
people in big cities
la
is so massively dense and the people who
live in these dense populated areas they
don't make food
they you've got house after house at
their houses maybe a small garden but
these people aren't going to be able to
sustain themselves in these big cities
what are they going to do now i don't
think the apocalypse is coming i don't
think it's going to be like come
november you go to the supermarket
there's people punching each other for
one can of beans maybe at some point in
the next few years depending on how how
bad things can get but it's going to be
like
what what the way they're describing it
is food costs going up 40 by the end of
the
year inflation on top last night i had a
dream that i went i saw the owner of the
old restaurant that i worked at in la i
saw and i was like do you own this
restaurant she went yeah and i get some
food i sat down to get like a reuben
sandwich and it was a hundred dollars in
the dream and i didn't think like uh oh
and crazy dreams i've been thinking
about inflation lately but that's just
like lightning struck my brand dude we
went out to get breakfast out here and
for like five people it was like a
hundred and something dollars and we
went to a diner we didn't go to like a
crazy place prices were nuts i mean
prices you even just go to the grocery
store try and buy a pound of ground beef
it's like seven eight bucks easy there's
there's a little barbecue shack by us
and last year they stopped selling
brisket and the guy said it was because
it was too expensive he was like there's
no point in trying to sell a 20 serving
of brisket no one will buy it and then i
got and then and then i'm on the hook
for it i just won't buy it at all do you
guys think that you will eat bugs you
will live in the pot you think factory
farming is a sin against god
uh well i'm not religious so we'll start
there um
so that's uh i think it's a shameless
question i was gonna ask sheamus i i i'm
not sure how you're defining factories i
believe there i believe there are ways
that are more or less ethical when it
comes to how we treat animals i was
taking the stink bugs out of my room and
throwing them outside and like they were
dying in the freezing and i asked god am
i gonna burn in hell for killing these
things and he said you're gonna
if you're gonna judge you for anything
it's for factory farming and it was like
all of you it was the statement of like
the human race will be judged harshly
for what you're doing to the animals in
factory farms
i believe it if there is a god that he'd
be pissed or it would be not happy with
the dis unity and the disorganization of
how we've corralled these things stuck
them with antibiotics to overgrow them
and just suck them but listen listen
i mean i will i will agree with you to a
certain extent just in a basic human
moral position that we do bad things in
in the name of profit to maximize how
much food we produce and now we have
very very cheap food and very very fat
homeless people so there is definitely
some weird disconnect going on with our
food economics at the same time we need
mass production of food to feed people
so they can live i'm into the stem cell
food have you guys looked at well i
don't want to change the subjects you
know maybe on the afternoon let's let's
operate with the assumption we don't
have it right now should we continue i
mean and i think
you know it's not ultimately it's not
the chicken and beef that are making
people fat right it's yeah it's the
sugar in the carbs
corn sugar the corn the corn you know
what it was for me i'm so michaela
peterson talks about how uh just
switching to an all-meat diet it's not
so much that all meat diet is good for
you but it's a but that it's an
elimination diet so when i cut out carbs
i cut out bread too
and then i've been
having some food and then testing it
turns out when i eat no gluten my whoop
recovery rate is through the roof when i
have bread it drops so i'm like that's
it brett's done we had that same
conversation last night exactly so when
you when you do an all meat diet yeah
that's good you're getting your b
vitamins you're getting it but it's all
the stuff that you're cutting out the
sodium benzoate the crappy uh
preservatives that they don't even put
on the label that they call natural
flavors you know that they get from like
a dissected bug or something you know
what you know what i ate today
out in the yard we have chives
everywhere
everywhere it's amazing they taste so
good it's nuts you can pick them right
off the ground and eat them i prefer to
wash them so i don't do that but
literally we walk outside and just grab
a big thing and just tear it off and
then chop it up threw it in some farm
fresh ground beef we got from a farm
down the road nice man that was that's
that's good eating
people i bring this up because when you
look at places like la or new york what
are they going to do
when food you know food is harder to
come by there was a movement to start
growing vegetables in the berm area of
uh la streets i don't know if you guys
saw that there was a guy pushing for it
four or five years ago like the middle
of the streets where they have like the
planters yeah between the sidewalk and
the road you know why that won't work
because people will just take it no
because it would fall on the ground rot
and then bugs come yeah
all over the streets it would be
different but if you could upkeep it
like you could the homeless people you
could give them money that's a job
incentive program to keep up keep the
gardens and just have that you can't
or anybody really that wanted a job the
problem is not yeah that's shellenberger
right he's really good on this the
problem the problem with homeless people
is not the lack of the home i shouldn't
even just say homeless like that that's
just they need or want that it's anybody
that could use a job that could be a
type of job as local farms road farms or
whatever you want to call them but they
are going to run out of food if they
don't
i don't know i mean i mean like most of
those sort of like urban gardening type
things are
not don't make sense in terms of scale
right the problem i mean you they just
don't understand how big like the farms
that actually feed us really are they're
massive
and you know when you're talking about
these small tiny little urban plots it's
like a you know yeah exactly and like
the most population is just a trivial
country a trivial contribution to the
overall food supply i like road or
rooftop gardens but they're cool they're
just not that meaningful in terms of
increasing the food supply of a city it
could like supplement your groceries
basically but if everyone does it i mean
it's a big ask i know just grow your own
food i mean it's kind of like duh
looking back and be like they didn't
used to grow their own so uh heck i was
reading one article that said people
should expect to be spending about a
thousand dollars a month for groceries
what what what is do we know the average
spend for a family per month on
groceries
i can look that up look it up
because uh
for me
i don't i don't i don't have a good
barometer of a high gross grocery cost
because when we buy groceries we buy for
the whole office which is like 30 people
so we spend a lot restocking everything
for everybody but i'm wondering what the
average person is spending per month on
groceries
it was 200 a week according to 2020 data
from the u.s bureau of labor statistics
that works out to 412 dollars per month
so it's gonna it's gonna more than so at
least one article i was reading was
saying expect your bills to your your
food cost to be about over a thousand
dollars i read that people should budget
an extra fifty two hundred dollars per
year for inflation starting so an extra
500 or so bucks for the food costs
yup thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you